I am now a connoisseur of on optimizing
Tim Ferris the king of self-optimization
going from thinking to thinking and
feeling there are compromises like in
terms of productivity it's falling
through the floor
[Music]
we're brought to you today by Roca
unlock 20 off your order with the code
richroll roca.com
[Music]
hear it
thank you for doing this I've been
looking forward to this for a while uh
the first time you did the podcast which
I believe was December 2017.
[Music]
a lot has happened since then a lot has
happened um I would say that you were in
a very different state than you are
today because when you arrived at my
house if memory serves me you had just
returned from a very intense uh silent
vipassana Retreat and it was clear that
you were trying to make sense of all of
it in real time
um you've been on a very interesting
um mental health uh Journey for yourself
um I'm just curious I think you know for
people that that are that are listening
or watching who maybe you know aren't
hip to some of the podcasts that you've
done around this it would be helpful to
kind of provide a back picture yeah yeah
totally so life I don't want to say
defined but characterized in part by
major depressive episodes for as long as
I can remember and this is
to the best of my knowledge largely
congenital this is code so it's it's
based on my genetics predictable or at
least the inclination is is predictable
so if I do any type of analysis that
comes up among other things
predisposition to depressive disorders
bipolar disorder Etc
and that has always been a huge
challenge that has led to many of the
different modalities different types of
therapy Etc that I've explored
especially in the last 15 years The
vipassana Retreat that you mentioned
which was a silent Meditation Retreat my
first extended silent Meditation Retreat
at Spirit Rock in Northern California
precipitated more dramatic action on my
part in many respects and I'll try to
keep it simple we can die we can dive
into any aspect of it that you would
like
but the the cliff notes version is I
went into this
I think underestimating just how
powerful and challenging such an
experience could be
I had a long-standing meditation
practice but these are 20-minute
sessions once or twice a day not
whatever it is six to eight six to ten
hours a day
and I decided with very poor judgment to
try to intensify it as much as humanly
possible because I thought it might be
the last time that I could spend time
with Jack cornfield in person who was
leading the event or co-leading the
event so I fasted for six days going
into it and did a whole host of other
things that
LED it to be
much more
high RPMs right because just going into
a silent Meditation Retreat on it on its
own is is not intense enough so let's
let's enhance this with five days of
fasting and then on top of that on top
of that I began
at the beginning micro dosing with
psilocybin and then
gradually stair stepping my way to
higher doses still what we would
consider sub-therapeutic dosing but
nonetheless these are all compounding I
would not recommend anyone do this as a
side note the conclusion is
I went into a full tailspin and
that was the experience of having this
childhood trauma which was childhood
sexual abuse from two to four
at the hands of a babysitter's son
replaying 24 7. when I say 24 7 I mean
every waking moment
this was a movie on Loop and and was
that a memory that previously you had
not been able to access or that you were
aware of but had repressed on some level
I only really became
very clearly re-aware of this a few
years prior I would say and I might be
mixing up the timeline a little bit but
clearly had been something and I do
think we want to be careful with the
topic of repressed memory because
our realities and memory are
in the present tense somewhat
constructed so we can fool ourselves we
have to be very careful with these
things
but in my case there were just there
were details that I could corroborate
and
it became patently clear to me that this
had happened and
that I'd locked it away in some
supposedly safe compartment to
not have an interfere with my life and
I had had this realization let's say in
other types of therapy specifically
using psychedelic compounds we can come
back to that there are many caveats and
warnings related to all of those uh all
of those things but I had the
realization and I was like ah that did
happen
that's terrible
and I don't think if I've made it this
long without unpacking that and spending
a lot of time in the deep end I don't
think I need to do that now and so I was
like yes I'm aware and
I'm going to leave that to the side in
The Meditation Retreat it became
clear to me because I was deathly afraid
that I wouldn't be able to function
after the retreat and I think without
Jack's intervention I set a time to
speak with him because you're not
speaking to folks generally but set a
time to speak with him and I said Jack
in effect I was like
I don't know if I'm gonna be able to
navigate life after this Retreat because
this is what's happening right now and
Jack for those people who don't know has
written a million books very skilled it
doesn't even really do him Justice to
say meditation practitioner and teacher
he's also a clinical psychologist has
done a lot of work with
veterans with say adolescents Cutters
with all sorts of different demographics
and psychographics he has a an
incredibly powerful and eclectic toolkit
if he had not been there I really
shuddered to think what that could have
led to
and I decided to put everything on pause
I was like okay
I don't know what fixing this or
addressing it or coming to peace with it
even looks like but right now this is so
front of mind that is blocking out
everything else and I should just do
what I do best which is going Whole Hog
into trying to at least examine this and
see what happens so that led to meeting
with many different therapists trying
many different modalities
and also talking about it publicly for
the first time I see it as uh like I use
the word Catalyst previously it was this
Catalyst for this journey that you've
been on and in many ways it's a journey
from the head to the heart like you're
somebody who I I think spends a lot of
time
intellectualizing things analyzing them
yeah deconstructing them right and this
is a very there is an aspect of that
that is applicable and beneficial in the
in the kind of healing Journey but
there's another piece that has to do
with letting go of all of that and
engaging with a different type of
intelligence I I would imagine for you
that was sort of new and and and and and
and kind of confusing maybe I don't want
to put words in your mouth but talk a
little bit about like confusing I think
that's a fair word to use I would say
one way to think about it would be going
from head to Heart another way to think
about it
which might be useful for framing my
experience would be from going from
thinking to thinking and feeling
if that makes sense and looking at
things in the rearview mirror I mean we
are doing our best to guess at causality
it's hard to say that a caused b or a
caused all these things although I will
say once the
once I began looking at the childhood
abuse clearly
the 17 disparate problems that I've been
trying to address in my life in a sense
I found relievingly addressable because
I was like oh these are all unrelated
independent problems most of these are
probably related to this big
elephant in the room right so so give an
example of that talk a little bit more
about that I would say well let me let
me I will talk about that uh give a
simple example if if you've shut off
certain types of feeling which I had
done
if you've learned to view emotion as a
liability
and
when you feel any inkling of certain
emotions you then have a
harsh inner critic to shut those things
down I think for someone like me who's
comfortable operating in spreadsheets
and dividing and conquering
deconstructing like you said it's like
okay well let's separate these things
out so it's not one big amorphous
problem here are these 17 different
problems and then how am I going to
address the first let me rank order
these and figure out which are the the
the most negative in terms of amplitude
of impact in my life okay
and that's one approach but if those are
symptoms that are presenting from a
problem that is underlying all of those
things
you're just going to be playing
whack-a-mole it's not going to be
Curative in any way and so fundamentally
I think
my not just healing Journey but journey
of becoming
hopefully more holy human experiencing
more of what life has to offer
which is good and bad or it includes the
good and the bad let's just say the
positive the negative the happy and the
sad
is bringing on lines sensitivities that
I took offline as a kid
I think that would be
one of the
perhaps
Crux
moves with respect to
looking forward instead of just
backwards like okay
what I've done up to this point what got
me here has worked on a whole lot of
levels
and
that's great
if you want to build
podcast if you want to write and launch
Books if you want to do any number of
things invest
this toolkit to date worked pretty well
there are side effects there are there's
some collateral damage along the way but
realizing I suppose a few things number
one is that this might be helpful for
folks out there I don't know
the the thinking toolkit right so this
hyper analytical thinking toolkit it's
not a bad thing but it can be a hammer
looking for nails furthermore
what I didn't want to do is throw that
away or discard it or lose a grasp on
that and become a hand wavy hyper
woo-woo I feel everything and I'm going
to trauma vomit on you within the first
15 minutes of visiting you your worst
nightmare which is quite a thing down
here in SoCal I got to tell you goodness
gracious but
we won't go there I'll just say I didn't
I I felt very uncomfortable with
putting on that hat as my primary hat
but if instead I looked at it as all
right
I have this very analytical way of
approaching things that's like having
a comfortable hoodie or a jacket I can
take it off put it in the closet I can
always go in and pick it back up and put
it back on if I want but now I'm going
to experiment with trying on different
jackets and see what that experience is
like
so I would say that has defined a lot of
what I've tried to focus on
the last however many years it's been it
feels like 100 years honestly from 2017
yeah to now I mean it feels like more
time has passed between 2017 and now
than when I was a kid in 2017 yeah
you look lighter you look happier you
look more comfortable in your own thank
you I thought you're gonna say you look
a lot older I don't know you don't look
older at all
you mentioned that idea of of you know
the 17 problems actually only being one
and that's that's kind of like a core
fundamental thing about really
understanding trauma and the way that it
operates
um in terms of behavior over time right
you think you have like I do this and I
do that I have all these problems
it's just one thing like if you can get
to the core of what that one thing is
start to understand it and and heal that
thing then miraculously all these other
patterns don't show up or show up less
frequently or with less intensity than
they would otherwise I mean that's
something I learned from
from Paul Conti that's that's been super
helpful and just kind of reflecting on
you know the little that I know about
you
um and and what this experience has been
like I think you know pretty good about
it yeah well what you share publicly
like you know we we haven't spent that
much time together you know off off the
mic but hopefully more but I I gather
that you know in certain respects we're
very different people the facts of our
our our kind of experiences are
different we live our lives in different
ways
um and we've kind of explored different
modalities in order to kind of make
sense of the world in in different ways
but when I hear you share your
internal monologue or when you kind of
relate
um you know the the emotional experience
of of where you were and kind of what
you went through and kind of where
you're at now the overlay between like
my experience and your experience is
it's not exact but there's a huge
overlap like I relate to your journey in
so many ways even though kind of the
things that I was doing and do now and
whatever may look different and then
here we are together today we kind of do
the same thing in the world a little bit
differently
um and we get to have this conversation
about those experiences and then and
then share them with broad audiences and
I think that's really a gift and my
sense is that this has has kind of
enhanced
um your sense of purpose and and given
you a deeper meaning in the work that
you do it it definitely has given me
a
Second Wind in a sense or a
forcing focusing function with a lot of
what I've done in the last handful of
years it's crazy to think that it's
only been five or six years since then
it's I'm still stuck on that a bit
because it just feels like it's been so
long yeah not not in a negative way
brings up separate questions we probably
don't want to get into about time
dilation and our experience of time and
things like that and you can live longer
just by changing your experience of your
day-to-day life which I think is a
non-trivial thing I'm not going to take
us too far down that side alley but
if you bring more of your faculties and
sensitivities back online or if you
simply develop those things your
perception of time broadens
which is kind of interesting it's like
if you're doing a lot of things
physically
to extend your life span you might want
to think about the experiential side as
well so that's footnote for me to
reflect on later
yes it's given me a lot of focus
and it's also raised a lot of questions
that I have wanted to explore publicly
in the sense that
my inclination previously with all the
various books right for our work week
for our body for our Chef whatever it
might be I'm doing years of research
taking years of notes interviewing
dozens of experts and then come to my
conclusions and I say here are my
conclusions here here's the index card
although my index cards tend to be 600
pages long but putting that aside
here's the index card and uh what I've
come to believe at least
with the long form audio format is I
think it is more helpful particularly
with something like mental health to
share the process and the struggles and
some of the confusion and the dead ends
so that people not only end up hopefully
with something they can use in the end
but they don't feel as alone in the
struggle yeah sure and there's a
there's something about listening to
somebody talk about it in real time it's
a it's a very different relationship to
words on a page they both have their
their benefits of course but there's a
connectivity like to hear somebody's
voice and to be able to emotionally
relate to that or connect to it
um I think
establishes like a a bond with whatever
is being shared that that is that can be
more meaningful right I think you know
the emotion comes through the honesty
the vulnerability is really powerful and
you know we had launched just before
coming over to do this and I was talking
about having our mutual friend Peter
attia on the podcast and exploring
similar terrain with him and and you
know how
um powerful that podcast ended up being
because of his willingness to talk about
uncomfortable things and we have that
fear of being vulnerable as if it's
going to kill us or we're going to die
if we share this certain thing and it
ends up being
this really powerful balm to so many
people who suffer in silence and feel
like they are alone or there is no hope
or there is no solution and uh or or
they're not they can't indulge in that
sort of solution and for you as somebody
who kind of tiptoed back from the
precipice of suicide and went through
what you did to come out the other side
and say Here's what worked here's what I
did here's what didn't work here's how I
feel with that level of like honesty
really opens up
a Gateway for other people to explore
things that they wouldn't do otherwise
and it's different from a book you can
read a book but it's not going to have
that kind of punch you know that the
voice is able to kind of create what a
thing The Voice language it and it can
make you feel more connected and less
alone in a way that the written word
struggles to I think and I would like to
mention
and we don't need to spend a lot of time
on it but if people are really having a
hard time two things the first is
of course if you're suffering from
suicidal ideation please call the
suicide hotline I also wrote a blog post
called some practical thoughts on
suicide about this chapter in my life in
college
that
resonated with a lot of people so if you
just search my name in suicide chances
are that'll be the first
result but if you're in acute need
please call Suicide Hotline and we can
put some of that in the show notes the
second is with respect to trauma and
sexual abuse specifically
I was initially planning on exploring
exploring perhaps discussing that and
that history of mine in a book
and my girlfriend at the time made the
point to me over dinner at one point she
said
You Realize by the time you write a book
A lot of people who could benefit will
have either passed away or killed
themselves or
become unreachable
and that's how I decided to do a podcast
podcast episode with Debbie Millman
specifically Debbie incredible designer
incredible teacher
also has childhood history of sexual
abuse and she and I had different
experiences and approached them trying
to
address them and
effectively completely different ways
and so we had a conversation about this
and our respective Journeys The Hope
being that people could pick and choose
and hear from two people who have made
progress using very very different
approaches yeah I would highly recommend
everybody who's listening or watching
this to uh please uh check that out I'll
link it up in the show now it's it's
incredibly powerful and not only for the
conversation that you have and the
different perspectives that you bring to
this but also all of the resources that
you guys kind of canvas over the course
of that conversation and you've kind of
put together this super comprehensive
list of links and and show notes um that
you can find on the on on on your blog
that corresponds with that episode yeah
I think it's just Tim dot blog slash
trauma people can search for it I've
done two episodes of Debbie the first
episode I don't think she'd ever spoken
about it publicly I asked her why
in the interviews I'd read I'd never
seen anything about her childhood and
she took this deep breath and then we
spent the rest of the time talking her
about her abuse which I and most people
had never heard about and that is why I
then felt
funny how Karma works or just
coincidence the fact that she had had
the courage to do that
then open the door for me after that
vipassana Retreat to reach back out to
her to ask for help and that's how we
ended up having the conversation I don't
know if you remember this but after you
did the podcast at my house that same
night I believe you did an event where
you interviewed Terry Crews hmm I
thought that was the same night right
yep who also has an analogous
story
in the same kind of Universe of this
terrain right yeah so looking like
through the Looking Glass you know
through the rear view mirror like this
you know you you you do the retreat you
come we kind of dance around the corners
of what was going on when you came to my
house and then you go talk to Terry
Crews and you've got Debbie Millman like
all these people are showing up and
lining up yeah the message the
consistent message is like it's okay to
talk about this stuff it's powerful it's
it's gonna be okay I almost canceled
that book launch
because I came out of this Retreat and
the book launch was coming up right I
don't know a month later and I just
thought to myself of all the things in
the world that I do not want to do right
now book launch this guy right very high
on that list
and I made a commitment to myself I
don't know if I've talked about this
publicly which was the only way this is
going to be something I feel remotely
good about doing is if in every
interview in every op-ed or whatever
contact I have with any type of media
I try to emphasize the importance of
cultivating self-love
in in addition to any type of
achievement and so that became my
homing Beacon for that entire process
but a lot of time to have a book launch
yeah that's wild
um self-love that's a tough one uh you
know as you're as you're talking about
that I'm thinking uh you know the Tim
Ferriss of I don't know 15 years ago
would have vomited in his mouth yeah
exactly right so this is what's tricky
about it right like I have a hard time
with self-love uh like yourself I'm
ambitious and competitive and I know how
to compartmentalize my emotions and
Channel all of those avoidant Tendencies
into workaholism and perfectionism and
you know collecting accolades and you
know receiving external validation and
kind of chasing that stuff right and so
I think there's an epidemic of people
out there who we develop in that kind of
internal family systems rhetoric of the
pieces that comprise us we have those
pieces that drive us in a certain way
out of an interest of protecting us that
get us to places where Society Smiles
upon us and we're affirmed in all the
ways that we want to be affirmed and
that is why so much of this kind of
operates in a pernicious you know
shadowy Nether world because although
the body is indeed keeping score it
takes a long time for that sort of
scoreboard to show up and and for these
you know kind of nascent
compartmentalized emotions to to Really
you know show up let alone you know turn
into a volcano so how do you think about
you know communicating to that that
younger version of yourself or that
person who's like I'm cool like you know
I got it together you know I know what
I'm doing I'll take a stab at it I would
say at first I just want to underscore
something you said earlier which is Paul
Conte I have a very high opinion of Paul
as a very skilled therapist and
practitioner also an excellent
communicator and writer so I just want
to encourage people who are perhaps
interested in exploring some of these
Corners to look up Paul
and then to the younger person maybe not
younger but person full of piss and
vinegar out there competing who thinks
they have it all together I'd say a
couple of things the first is that
there's a season for everything and
maybe they're just not
to that season yet would the
Tim meaning myself with the Tim of 25
benefited from uncorking all of this
then I'm not sure I don't know I think
that there are certain practices that
probably would have been a good idea to
add to the mix
meditation not long meditation events
short daily meditation
a few other things maybe DBT
uh for instance
very forward-looking therapy tends not
to
focus on any narrative about the past
but really focus on like present and
moving forward behavioral change that
would have I think been palatable to a
Tim of 25 in a way that a lot of the
things we're talking about wouldn't have
been for some people there will come a
point where you realize that you have
blind spots other people will make that
very clear to you and you may also
realize once you check some of the boxes
once you have some of the success once
you make some of the money whatever once
you have the relationship you thought
you needed that would make you happy
once you have some of those things and
you realize wait a [__] minute
my movie is still the same in my head or
very similar I'm still waking up anxious
I'm still having trouble going to bed
I'm still feeling depressive symptoms
whatever those things might be
and there can be biochemical issues
genetic issues and so on but if you
think it might be related to your
perception or reality and the stories
that you tell yourself
I think at that point you're more open
to engaging with these things certainly
if I reflect on my own experience I
always held out hope
and I believed that once X once y
all this stuff just goes away sure right
yeah and and even when even when you
kind of know it's not you're still
holding out hope because it's always one
wrong away on the ladder and hope is no
small thing right so
I
I wouldn't want to take
a hope away from someone and not give
them an equally powerful substitute I
think that
is risky so I would say if you're at the
point where you're recognizing okay The
Jig Is Up
I think there's some inner game that I
need to work on then I'd say great uh
you know stair step your way in and
begin to look at some of the tools that
have been vetted and listen to people
you trust but get professional opinions
also right don't just rely on YouTube or
podcasts or anything else like we really
need some degree of professional
interaction ideally I would also say
that we're talking about the performance
side let's just say the competitive
performance side yeah I think there's
also on the opposite end of the spectrum
perhaps a trauma performance side which
is why I tread into these Waters pretty
lightly because if you go to my hometown
of Austin as an example you will meet
people I'm not exaggerating this within
five minutes of meeting you they are
telling you all about
they're awful horrific childhood abuse
and it takes on a performative flair
sure it's like my trauma can beat up
your trauma or my Shaman can beat up
your shama and it's the same as
wanting a nicer car than your neighbor
but without the the negative judgment
maybe that someone would have if they
were driving around like a Lamborghini
in Austin right crafting a whole
identity around uh it's the same ego a
narrative that you've spun about the
trauma that becomes a defining character
it becomes it had to be a big fear with
you in sharing this because I you're
obviously you know that you're someone
who would be very adverse to be
like sort of aligned with that
sensibility yeah and it's I think it's
become
a lot worse in the last few years
and I would just say
as a check I think it's helpful to ask
yourself if I could not tell anyone
about this would I still do it would I
still take it seriously
this applies to a lot of things
including psychedelics right okay great
you're gonna go to a retreat and fill in
the blank location and have this
assisted psychedelic experience if you
could not tell anyone you couldn't post
it on Instagram you couldn't write a
blog post about your neon crocodile
Epiphany or whatever the [__]
would you do it if the answer is no then
you're doing it for the wrong reasons
and you shouldn't do it
and I think that's true for a lot of the
therapeutic stuff also now it's going to
sound hypocritical because here I am
with a mic in front of my face talking
about this stuff
but I would simply say that there are
Shadow aspects to the external
validation High performing competitor
end of the spectrum and also on the
hyper vulnerability trauma side of the
spectrum so just be aware of those uh
but I would say to someone who is
beginning to feel maybe the tires get a
little wobbly on the race car I think
you probably want to start to look at
this before they blow off when you're on
the Autobahn yeah
we're brought to you today by Roka
glasses are not something you normally
think about as a piece of performance
gear which when you think about it is
kind of insane because you can't perform
at your best if you can't see well the
Geniuses at Roka basically rebuild
eyewear from the ground up no matter how
active you are or how much you sweat
these things never slip or fall off your
face they're super durable they look
awesome and they've got tons of super
classy modern styles to choose from I've
been rocking roca's for about four years
at this point I love them I'm a big fan
of the Hamilton style and gloss black
that's this Frame right here as well as
clear or I guess they call them vintage
on the website and if you want to try
them out for yourself you can do that
right now and unlock 20 off your order
with the code Rich Roll at roca.com or
you can click the link in the
description below okay back to the show
to your point of you know the
impenetrable 25 year old Tim Ferriss I
mean willingness is not something you
can you can foist upon another human
being like they have to come to that on
their own so
um but if you find yourself slightly
curious and receptive to these ideas
that might be something to you know kind
of hang on to the way I would sell it
here's the way I would sell it so
if you're like your task should you
choose to accept it is to travel back in
time and convince 25 year old Tim
Ferriss to do some
some prehab so that he doesn't explode
into a million psychic fragments during
a vipassana retreat many years later I
would say okay
I would position it not
inaccurately as
a performance enhancing set of tools
right you just you shift the language
right to make it sound like you're it's
some kind of optimization protocol this
is and and it's not a lie like these
things are going to help you with your
heart rate variability these things are
going to help you with your recovery
these things are going to help you make
better decisions these things are going
to help you assess businesses
okay yes now I can hear you yeah and all
of those things are true I think
make more strategic decisions prioritize
more effectively I do think all of that
is true so that's how I would sell it I
wouldn't bring up inner child I wouldn't
bring up parents yeah you got to speak
speak the right language right
um and I think it it also requires kind
of addressing this idea especially in
the case of of the kind of hyper
achiever there is an irrational
attachment to these patterns or
behaviors that you may know probably
aren't sustainable or maybe not in your
best interest but they've been so
effective they are indeed the superpower
like how dare you ask me to let go of it
or tell me that I would be better off
without it that's you know like
Annihilation even with meditation I
think one of the most common worries and
I had this worry it's like I'm gonna
lose my Edge
and I have
never seen that to be an issue with a
high performer ever right
it's just like you don't need to you
don't need to be in park but maybe you
should learn to use some gears other
than sixth gear right right yeah it's
part of being a good driver yeah but
there's something about like being on
that that you know the highs and the
lows and the the kind of you know
hedonic cycle of the whole thing that is
kind of addictive and it feels very
uncomfortable to step off of that and be
in a place of kind of ease and
acceptance with things because
like if I'm not pushing or putting
myself you know in a in a in into some
level of suffering to
achieve whatever I try to have it worked
yeah it's like this is worthless this is
not you know this is of no value yeah so
my life is I think
uh sort of the choir to that song yeah
and
me too I have found a lot of what we're
talking about to do
nothing negative to that it allows you
to let go a lot of the hyper activity in
service of focusing on the critical few
things that actually matter and that's
true personally not just professionally
I would also maybe share with folks
this is going to seem self-evident to a
lot of folks but if you're having a mild
allergic reaction to all the talk of
therapists and inner work and this that
and the other thing I get it
and if I had to choose all the talk
therapy in the world or consistent
physical exercise I would choose
consistent physical exercise like
regimented planned physical exercise
that is
a critical leg on the stool or the table
of my mental health and from a
physiological standpoint from a
neurochemical standpoint it makes all
the sense in the world and there are
many books on this many many research
papers and so on but
I would I would say that is the one
thing I did right when I was younger
because I was competing it's harder when
you're not competing at least for me
and that definitely without my realizing
it perhaps was
the the buoy that kept my head above
water yeah I mean it certainly served
that for me as well but it's not an
either or it's not a it's not important
it's not I'm just widening the funnel
right so yeah people are like talk
therapy not my jam I'm like great maybe
you should do rowing workouts a few
times a week right one of the things
that that you talked with Debbie about
in that podcast was this idea of of
kind of hope you mentioned hope a few
minutes ago the idea that like hope
having hope like like a step ahead of
Shame right like this idea that hope
just needs to outpace The Shame by a
little bit in order to kind of be in the
solution can you kind of like elaborate
on that idea sure uh I will
uh couch it in an anecdote that I
haven't thought of in a long time I was
having a
hike with a close friend of mine a very
successful investor
has a number of kids and I asked him
what advice he would give to a new
parent or someone considering becoming a
parent and he gave two or three bits of
advice but the very first one was it's
not your kid's job to love you it's your
job to love them you chose to bring them
into the world second piece of advice
was above all else teach your kids to be
optimistic because that is the mother
quality of so many other things and in
that conversation with Debbie we talked
about
our experiences we talked about our
approaches we talked about things that
worked and didn't work and those tools
may or may not map to someone else
but if they get to the end of the
conversation they think
thank God
at least I have an example of two people
who have made progress so I feel like
there's light at the end of the tunnel
that seems like a prerequisite to taking
any kind of meaningful action you need
to have some belief that there might be
light at the end of the tunnel or some
degree of relief maybe not a cure with
some degree of relief particularly when
it comes to
sexual abuse
it's a head trip you know it can do a
lot of damage and
I
think there can be a lot of Shame
associated with it
uh the the shame for me is not this
might sound strange is is not the big
issue a bigger issue I think is the
belief
that
and many people have this belief like I
am broken and there's no fixing it which
is more hopelessness than a shame so I
think keeping the hope just a step ahead
of hopelessness is really important so
seeing someone perhaps with a similar
experience doesn't have to be the same
but like you were describing earlier how
we have in terms of our inner experience
maybe a lot of similarities even though
we've lived Our Lives differently we've
had different paths coming across
someone who perhaps has that inner
critic
who's driving so many of our choices and
seeing that they found a way to work
with it maybe not subjugate it probably
not subjugated but work with it maybe
witness it maybe add in an additional
voice
is is really important because without
some degree of Hope and I would say that
for decades I mean hopelessness has been
more prevalent than hope for me for sure
it's just like yeah I'm broken in these
following ways
those are never going to change we'll
see how it goes that was the base
assumption
I mean that's so heavy because at the
same time while you're harboring that
sense of self you're still you know
you're you're kind of showing up in the
world in this you know hyper successful
manner that serves as this like mask to
the real Tim inside like if that's
really how you're feeling about yourself
for such a long period of time is that
true I would say
I've tried very hard I think I've been
successful and this is part of why
I feel so much freedom in what I do
professionally I've I've recognized that
we become the mask we wear for too long
and I've had advice from people who
really know what they're doing like
Andrew Zimmern and others who would say
be careful what you pretend to be on
that first episode of that TV pilot
because if it's successful now that's
who you need to be right and I've seen a
lot of YouTubers also paint themselves
into Corners where suddenly they have to
be the X Y or Z person so I don't feel
like I don't feel like I was ever
presenting something that was fake or
presenting a mask
but my genuine feeling was I think for a
very long time internally I'm a broken
toy
inner voice depression fill in the blank
these are just flaws that are
to be lived with because they cannot be
fixed therefore let me focus on some
things I can control and having a really
high pain tolerance and being really
good at extended focus and competing and
winning I'm good at that so let me just
focus on what I'm good at and there is a
half truth in there which is focus on
the things that you can change don't
focus on the things you have no power
over
but there's a very debilitating
assumption in there which is I cannot
change in a meaningful way my interior
experience and I'm very happy to say
that that has proven incorrect there are
things you can do
I would also say that
no one bullet is a Panacea
and you're an athlete I have been an
athlete in Prior lifetimes and you would
never say all right I did this amazing
workout and I'm done I am fit forever
right that's just not how it works some
things may have more durable effects
than others you may have
orthopedic surgery on your knee and you
do prehab and Rehab but if you don't do
your rehab or you don't continue to
focus on stability and so on you are
going to have related problems again and
that can be a tough pill to swallow I
think especially with
some of the showcasing of Mental Health
where people want to talk about the
successes so either genuinely they
believe that they've had a breakthrough
that has fixed everything and will last
forever
and they want to proselytize we run into
this a lot it's especially problematic
in psychedelics right now or you find
someone who simply recognizes that this
is like working out you need to maintain
it is very hard to sell
so I'm going to put something short on
Tick Tock I'm going to either talk about
how terrible things are for sympathy
play or I'm going to talk about how this
thing completely changed my life which
will give people false hope
and
the takeaway though from everything that
I just spewed out in word salad is it's
been a revelation to realize that you
can actually change your interior
experience quite reliably if you find a
handful of things
that help and those those things exist
people are using them what is the
internal monologue now in contrast to
the negative prior version I'm about to
give you
rich and everyone listening very
dissatisfying answer
goes up and down goes up and down I
would say I have more awareness of my
thoughts and emotions now so I can look
at them and to myself say I notice that
I'm having the thought
X as opposed to being X does that make
sense sure and there are many ways to
approach this I think the introductory
course on the waking up app was Sam
Harris it's very basic I'm going through
the introduction course again and not
that I'm some llama Or Yogi but I've
done a fair amount of meditating and
still I'm like you know what my foul
shots are Rusty I need to just go back
to basic basic basic basic complexity is
super sexy and appealing I think
especially the smart people are like
this is a problem I'm good at solving
problems let me find something really
complicated but sometimes you just need
to like step on that line and shoot
shots my inner monologue is heavily
dependent on having a sense of purpose
which over at least the last five years
I've been very fortunate to have with
the mental health Therapeutics I think
humans need purpose they could be raking
the garden it does not really matter
what that purpose is but you need to
feel like there is a focusing purpose
need is a strong word most humans
benefit from them there are days though
where particularly if there's certain
factors at play I didn't sleep well it's
really overcast
uh because I didn't sleep well I wake up
groggy and it takes me a few hours to
get going and then I feel like I'm
behind the eight ball those days suck
yeah and then sometimes I'm like you
know what it's been a while let me turn
myself into a punching bag let's play
that game yeah so it still happens
after everything I've done oh I know
it's just he's like [__] yeah you can't
even deal with a cloudy day yeah exactly
exactly so you know you know this movie
yeah so so very well so that still
happens but here's here's maybe the the
metric that is more concrete and I'm I
didn't track these things so I'm
estimating but let's just say for my
adult life three to four major
depressive episodes a year which would
span weeks or in some cases months
that was every year without Phil
and since 2000 let's call it 13 I would
say by and large one every two years
that's the difference between this too
is two different people yeah yeah that's
a lot of growth and a lot of work that
you've put into that grow through all
these different modalities and you know
maybe we can spend a couple minutes on
some of the more helpful resources
um like we talked about they're all on
your blog but there's there's a quote
that kind of recurs that I've heard you
say a couple times it to me it almost
acts like a Talisman or or a way into
this process and I believe it's Tara
Brock who said it focusing on like or
thinking about what it is that you're
unwilling to feel yeah right like as a
as a that like really kind of like pulls
focus on totally where to begin
yeah the terabrock
and I really recommend I'm actually
rereading it right now
radical acceptance some of you may
find that a bit nauseating in title and
I also was sort of repelled by this very
generic title but it was recommended to
me by uh PhD in Neuroscience who's not
in the woo camp at all
and I read it many years ago and I found
it so helpful and I've been recommending
it and recommending and recommending it
I recommended some of the week you know
what maybe it's time for me to reread
that so I dug back into it and I think
it is in radical acceptance tarabrock
b-r-a-c-h I think it is in that book
maybe at the head of one of the chapters
where she says a wise Sage once said
there is only one question that really
matters what is it that you are
unwilling to feel
that is a very focusing question
so that is a good place to start
I'm a journaling junkie I really find
that it is difficult to think clearly or
to even learn what you think without
trapping it on paper so you can examine
the thoughts they're very difficult to
capture or cross-examine without putting
them on paper morning pages I find very
very helpful for this so in terms of
tools and feel free to to direct me in
any way that you'd like
but in terms of just a handful of tools
there are ongoing tools and then there
are inputs in the form of books I would
say there are a few that have really
impacted me I've already mentioned
radical acceptance I would put that
pretty high on the list another book
which is shorter and easier to complete
but that many people find super abrasive
is a book called awareness by Anthony
Demello it's a short book it's mostly a
cleaned up transcript of public lectures
that he gave Jesuit priest and
psychotherapist who is who has since
passed he has a very no BS approach to
things which some people find very
offensive I like that kind of tough love
coach type Vibe so it works for me
the
waking up app introductory course I
think for people who have never
meditated who have the opinion which I
did for a very long time it just ain't
for me sitting still
whatever you do I don't think I can do
that my mind's all over the place the
waking up app
introductory course presents a logical
sequence of skill development that is
what makes it I think unique and very
appealing it's 10 minutes each morning
and do it for a month your life I think
will change
your awareness of the scripts that are
running your life
will become more acute
and then I would say
focusing on sleep first and foremost and
I've had you know number chats with Matt
Walker of UCSF
on my podcast really focusing on sleep
since I've had lifelong issues with
insomnia ons insomnia specifically Tim
on consistent good sleep for even three
days and Tim on mediocre sleep for three
days those are two different Tims
so really making the compromises
necessary taking the actions necessary
for instance like zone two or higher
level aerobic training which
historically I hate I hate it with a
passion I would much rather go into the
gym and do sets of five with heavier
weights I hate aerobic I exercise
generally however I found a few that
seem to a dramatically improve my mood
and really help me sleep
for whatever set of reasons and then we
can talk about
perhaps the the one that I've been not
so definitely maybe super obviously
navigating around which is psychedelic
assisted therapy that that is the
amplifier that is the tool that has
allowed me most consistently
to take an observer
seat where I can look at the beliefs and
behaviors
that I take for granted that are
automatic that I think are unavoidable
or that I don't think about at all that
are dictating the quality of my life or
the self-punishment that I'm inflicting
so let's let's get into that
um I'm super curious about this world
it's actually you know kind of at the
core of of the work that you do now you
have this Foundation you funded science
uh you've been doing that for many years
you've had your own personal experiences
with this and and I come
into this as somebody who who had a lot
of opinions uh and many of those
opinions have changed like I really have
changed my mind
um about this world and the efficacy of
these powerful compounds in terms of
helping people with a variety of of
conditions from PTSD to depression
addiction Etc I I'm somebody who has not
done it myself so I can't speak from any
position of experience and I also come
into it indoctrinated in kind of 12-step
uh and that's sort of my That's my kind
of language and modality that helped
kind of save my life and and keeps me
sober
and that of course then
colors
my receptivity to the possible benefits
available through this and like I said
I've really I've kind of opened my
awareness to what's going on and you've
been kind of at the Forefront of all of
this so walk me through how you got
interested in this how they have
benefited you personally and what you're
seeing in the emerging science and and
kind of the the the the purpose and
functionality of the of the non-profit I
am happy to cover all of that that's a
lot and that's a whole podcast I can
cover it yeah I can cover it and I would
like to start with a few disclaimers so
the first is
not a doctor not a psychiatrist I play
neither on the internet so please do
your own homework and talk to
professionals
the second is that these are and there
are many different types many different
classes so when when someone says
psychedelics
it's used very broadly in a sense it's
become almost almost meaningless in a
colloquial
use because it's applied to many things
that I wouldn't characterize as
psychedelic but suffice to say that
there are many different types of
psychedelic compounds and there are some
that are adjacent let's just say MDMA
which I would consider more of an
intactogen
and that has particular applications in
in a clinical setting now to complex
PTSD and the results are truly
astonishing in terms of what can be
accomplished in two or three sessions
with the appropriate therapeutic wrapper
there are many different classes and
they are useful and dangerous or benign
in different ways so I just want people
to know it's it's hard to speak about
psychedelics very broadly I will say
that from a
from a scientific and also anecdotal
perspective just because the science has
pretty much been on Ice largely on Ice
since the Nixon Administration since
these compounds let's just say
psilocybin as found in water usually
termed magic mushrooms so philosophy
mushrooms or LSD
and mescaline and so on these are
schedule one compounds they are very
difficult to work with in a university
setting for research purposes
however in places like Northern
California and many others there are
facilitators who have worked with these
things for decades and had thousands and
tens of thousands of sessions and I take
that experience quite seriously so what
I'm going to say is yes I think
supported by a good amount of the
research that has been done at places
like Imperial College London where I've
uh
funded quite a bit and was one of the
founding funders of the first dedicated
research facility there
and then also Johns Hopkins and
elsewhere
if you think about and this is a
Layman's
description of course but if you think
about let's just say the sort of river
of the psyche and you can swim in this
River I'm just swimming Downstream and
on one side on one Shore you have
hyper rigidity and that would
at least if we're using the DSM which
has its own issues but diagnostic manual
for different psychiatric disorders and
so on that might include things like OCD
it might include things like chronic
depression where you have a certain Loop
that you play or can't seem to escape
chronic anxiety same situation Eating
Disorders like anorexia nervosa where
in some fashion and I'm generalizing but
people are exerting some type of control
often because they experienced what felt
like a loss of control
or something uncontrollable earlier
and it could just be genetic
predisposition maybe it's not associated
with the trauma but there's this hyper
rigidity
certain psychedelics seem to be very
helpful for hyper rigidity
if you go to the other side to the shore
where you find let's just call it hyper
chaotic or maybe that sounds too
negative but let's just say
hyperchaotic and you might have
conditions like schizophrenia or
borderline personality disorder those
people would be excluded from
consideration for studies with
psychedelics as it stands today and I
think generally it's a very good idea to
stay away from these compounds if you
have a family history of anything like
that so I just wanted to put that on the
table first in terms of my interest you
may not even know this I don't know if
I've talked about the way way back story
my interest in psychedelics goes way
back into the 90s so I have
neurodegenerative disease on both sides
of my family so we have Alzheimer's
Parkinson's and so on are real
Motley selection of lovely things
and dying at this point and certainly
even then in dying as a question mark of
All Sorts but it dying didn't scare me
as much as The Descent towards death and
having witnessed
severe cognitive decline let's just say
my grandmother that horrified me and not
wanting that from my parents and trying
to find a way to avoid it was also way
at the top of my priority list so when I
first
went to college I was a neuroscience
major I intended to focus on all things
Neuroscience to try to figure out a way
to Stave off these conditions in the
process of taking classes with some
amazing professors this is at Princeton
Bart Hobel at the time I mean some real
grain groundbreaking scientists
and then also becoming fascinated by
this research who I think recently
passed sadly Barry Jacobs I became
exposed to some of the research around
psychedelics such as it was at the time
or at least a scientific interest which
was very rare and Barry had an interest
Professor Jacobs I guess if I'm being
more respectful and around the same time
I had my first recreational experiences
with mushrooms specifically in
completely uncontrolled you can imagine
right College settings like Grateful
Dead concert Vibe not so much Grateful
Dead it would be a small gathering of
friends for a birthday or something like
that and I observed a few things my
personal experience while I'm
simultaneously becoming very interested
in the effects these compounds have on
the brain one
they were just the most bizarre
experiences I had ever had in my life
words failed to describe how bizarre
these experiences were
and secondly I had this Afterglow of
three to six months where I would not
get depressed
and for that reason I for a period of a
few years used mushrooms once a year and
then I had a horrifying and very
dangerous experience where because we
had no facilitators or any type of adult
supervision
I took mushrooms with two of my friends
and they left to go on a walk somewhere
and it was like the middle of the night
so I'm left in this house by myself
I start looping which can happen on
these things start believing that maybe
my friends are imaginary not a great
feeling and I go outside to like figure
out my life to walk around in the dark
and this is this is in a very rural spot
on the east coast and to cut to the end
as I'm coming out of this experience I
come out of it because headlights are
coming at me and I'm standing in the
middle of a street on a country road and
almost get hit by a car and I managed to
get to the side but that's scared the
[__] out of me so badly as it should
that I just concluded no more no mas I'm
done with these and so I I didn't use
them at all
until around 2012
when I saw a girlfriend at the time
completely transformed by
in this particular case a multiple day
trip to South America where she consumed
Ayahuasca on two consecutive nights
which is a big gun and I think pretty
high risk for a lot of people I just
want to mention that up front but she
knew me very very well we'd been
together a long time and she came back I
was going through a very strenuous
period in my life this was around the
four hour chef and I had very
imprudently but this shouldn't shock
anyone based on what we've been talking
about decided that it would be a great
idea to cram a three to four year
project into like a year maybe a year
three months of course and I can do this
at oh if the writing weren't enough
let's make this my first four color book
and I'm gonna do all the photography
just to learn how to do photography or
something like half the photography
right turns out and I do it like outside
of traditional publishing and to do it
outside of traditional publishing and to
get boycotted by everyone because it was
the first major title out of Amazon
publishing
and this entire situation led to
using stimulants nothing illicit but
just taking like pre-workout supplements
and tons of coffee and so on to stay up
stay up really poor sleep and just
letting that compound over months and
months and months and months
I was in bad shape psychologically and
emotionally just very ragged and my
girlfriend came back and I was I was
hitting a breaking point I recognized
that it was probably past the breaking
point who am I kidding and two things
came out of that a friend of mine said
you should try TM and the more I read
about it the more I was like absolutely
not this sounds ridiculous if you read
the history but Transcendental
Meditation he said look you're a [__]
mess what do you have to lose you can
afford the training like stop it just go
do it I was like okay
and then she sold her experience to me
because I saw a durable change in her as
15 years of therapy and two nights and I
was like right sales pitch for the right
guy she knows who she's talking to
and I decided to not jump in with both
feet I think that's a huge mistake but
to actually tiptoe in re-familiarize
myself with the science
if there were any new science or newer
science compared to what I tried to dig
up
way back in the days undergrad and to
look at options for facilitated
experiences with mushrooms
then and only then if pass go safely
with proper
uh guard rails to consider
Ayahuasca and so that was my re-entry
into considering these things which I
did in a very systematic methodical way
and I was able to prove to myself with
the help of very experienced
facilitators that you can
the proper medical intake with the
proper screening with the proper
lead in and lead out with the proper
therapy in place as a safety net in case
something goes sideways which most
people neglect to think about there are
circumstances in which these things can
have profound therapeutic effects and
they're generally very well tolerated
physiologically if we're talking about
say psilocybin magic mushrooms
generally I would say
anti-addictive
physiologically well tolerated
and Incredibly versatile for a number of
conditions and if you remember from
earlier the river I described on the
hyper rigid side there are a whole lot
of conditions that might be treated
separately conventionally that I lumped
together
and in part that's because those
conditions many of them seem to respond
well to
say psilocybin treatment and it raises a
lot of questions because it upends some
of our assumptions about how Psychiatry
or mental health treatment should work
but that is how I got back in
and began doing what I do best which is
researching researching researching
interviewing interviewing interviewing
and that led me then a few years later
to conclude after I saw changes in
myself including the frequency of major
depressive disorders this and I'm
borrowing from Stan Groff is a famous
psychotherapist but that this has the
potential psychedelics have the
potential to do for the mind
what
say the
microscope did for biology and what the
telescope did for astronomy I think
Super bold statement it's a super bold
statement and I am at a point where
I feel that is absolutely true and there
are some very significant risks but as
soon as I have
so people may not know but my other
career because I lived in the Bay Area
for 17 years was Angel Investing and I
invested in a lot of tech and had a
couple of Lucky hits and
right before my my my biggest lucky hit
struck I called the number of people to
ask about uncrowded vets in science
early State science related to
psychedelics because there was a stigma
attached this is around 2000 15 probably
and there was effectively no funding
there were individual philanthropists
here and there most people were worried
about blowback some type of problem
reputationally so there's effectively no
funding Maps didn't exist map did exist
and Maps had been pounding the pavement
mostly for MDMA
assisted Psychotherapy for complex PTSD
and I helped raise about
in total about 30 million dollars for
their phase three trials which have
turned out very very well thus far
but for earlier stage say pilot studies
at Hopkins which was one of my first
studies I helped fund with psilocybers
psilocybin assisted Psychotherapy
effectively as a treatment for or
intervention for treatment resistant
major depressive disorder okay so you
have major depressive disorder that has
failed
a number of interventions already there
was next to no money for that type of
thing and I called a few people
knowledgeable in the space to say all
right where are the high leverage
uncrowded bets because I'm about to have
a decent amount of money for the first
time
and this is where I want to focus my
efforts so that's how it started and we
could talk about
the projects that scissor Foundation
have funded but a lot of Firsts yeah
well let me interject at this point I
mean that was super helpful thank you
you characterize this sort of diagnostic
approach as being you know on the shores
of you know two sides of a river and and
I sort of think of this and please you
know correct me if I'm wrong on the one
hand there is the application of these
compounds to uh you know address a
certain
um piece of mental health gone awry in a
certain way that is perhaps treatment
resistant in other ways and then on the
other hand there is just the notion of
kind of Consciousness Liberation right
that isn't necessarily Tethered to
anything wrong just the kind of prison
of our minds right you hear Sam Harris
talk about this and the transformative
experience that he had with MDMA early
on in his life that kind of
shifted how he sees the world and his
place in it like that's a different kind
of like way to you know kind of approach
these things so I think people come to
these with an either or either they're
looking to solve a problem or they're
looking for some kind of expanded you
know Peak experience right yep
um and so with that
um I like and I appreciate how conscious
you are
about
the importance of guard rails and
protocols and intentionality and the
prehab in the rehab and the follow-up
and the accountability that goes into
all of this because I do have this
concern
around the mainstreaming of all of this
in the sense that no matter how much you
give your kind of preface about what you
advise and what you advise against
all people here is
I got 15 years of therapy done in two
nights that's what I want sign me up
where do I go Tim right yeah and it
doesn't matter because because that's
the way human beings are and I'm no
difference I'm like wow that sounds
amazing right we don't want to do all
the other stuff that you did we wanna
you know we want to four hour it right
in some certain way and we see this kind
of as something that's already happened
with micro dosing and I'm sure you have
a perspective on that and even marijuana
with the legalization of marijuana and
the kind of apple storification of
dispensaries and this kind of narrative
that pot should be part of your daily
Wellness routine without any
appreciation or responsibility for the
potency and and and and and you know
kind of negative power that some of
these compounds hold right so you know I
am always quick to like kind of hit the
brakes and sound a little bit of a
cautionary alarm around this because I
do think that we have a predisposition
to try to find the end run around you
know the thing that ails us so that we
can you know do it with the least amount
of of kind of effort toil and time here
here you're preaching to the choir and
we were chatting before we started
recording actually it was at lunch and I
was saying that one of my exes would be
at say group dinner with me frequently
when someone would bring up psychedelics
want to talk about it and the first
response that she would have was oh God
here we go again right should still hear
this conversation for the 500th time the
second thing that she always found
amusing was that generally folks expect
me to proselytize and if they've made a
decision to fly to some God forsaken
place in the middle of nowhere to take
some mystical brew that I'm going to be
very supportive and I talk way more
people out of using psychedelics than I
talk into using sex villains which folks
might find surprise but
I would take a step back I agree with
everything you just said and I would
revise the 15 years of therapy in two
nights I wouldn't actually use the 15
years of therapy I would say there is
this really high risk but potentially
High reward Neurosurgery
that requires two nights and a lot of
prep and a lot of rehab afterwards in
some people
they say it as the effect of 15 years of
therapy
people think about it very differently
if it were phrased that right there's a
there's a there's an appreciation of
risk there that yeah as one as one
scientist put it I don't know if he's
put it publicly but he might have I
don't want to name his name just in case
but
you are working with nuclear power
when you're using these compounds and
my position would be you're creating and
this is dramatically simplified so I'm
not using these terms in the way that
certain scientists would but I'll try to
keep it simple you are
you're inducing a window of plasticity
within which you can reshape in some
cases your stories beliefs
world view
and that can turn out well but you know
you can also heat up the Play-Doh and
fumble it and drop it on a floor that
has dog hair all over it and then you
have a real situation on your hands and
people do not always turn out better and
there are Adverse Events there are
significant Adverse Events there are
people who
have
tried to stop their meds their other say
psychiatric meds cold turkey in order to
go to some Retreat and then throw
themselves off off a balcony I mean
these things happen they just don't get
much AirPlay because
that is not the Zeitgeist at the moment
the majority of reporting is positive
which is fine uh I mean part of the
reason that I have a fellowship with UC
Berkeley that helps fund for journalism
fellows is to get a broader scope of
coverage in long-form pieces which I
think is extremely important
and 99 of the people who claim any
competence with these compounds are
either delusional or lying I hate to put
it that way but it's true I mean you
can't throw a rock in La New York City
or any number of other cities without
hitting someone who calls themselves a
shaman right and you know what is the
solution to that
is there is there space for a
responsible you know response
responsible kind of like regulatory
oversight and there has to what would
that look like there has to be yeah I am
not someone who believes it's a good
idea
to have nuclear power available at the
local 7-Eleven
I think that's terrible idea I think it
is a terrible idea to have really strong
THC available THC containing products
available to a lot of people I mean
and look I'm going to get a bunch of
grief for this because cannabis users
love their cannabis and I'm a fan also
for a lot of reasons in a lot of
settings but you take someone who steers
let's just say congenally towards the
chaotic side of the river and you give
them the type of weed or products that
are available now which are incredibly
or can be mercilessly strong there are
psychotic breaks and people develop
extended
paranoid experiences I mean these are
well documented yeah I've seen it I've
seen it and you can you can disrupt your
sleep architecture right this is well
established so
that is not to say that I am by any
means an anti-drug Crusader the fact
that I'm here talking about this and
funding all the science that I'm funding
which is a significant percentage of my
total net worth that I've put into all
this is because I believe in the
potential of these compounds and I think
in order for let's just say even tens of
thousands well let's push it a little
hundreds of thousands of people to be
treated responsibly with these compounds
in a way that doesn't lead to all sorts
of terrible outcomes
you need regulation I'm sorry guys you
need to have vetting you can't just have
every person who's done a yoga retreat
and watched some YouTube videos
available for dispensing really powerful
drugs there's a reason we have the FDA
like if anyone listening wants to go
back to like the wild west to buy snake
oil out of the back of some wagon from a
traveling salesman you're welcome to try
to revert to that but I think it's it's
a bad idea and these agencies have their
challenges and their issues I get it but
there are very good reasons why we have
drug regulation and I'm not saying these
things should be treated exactly the
same but I do I do think for these
things
to reach let's just call a small
fraction of the people affected by
treatment resistant depression or
substance substance use disorders which
is one of the primary indications right
so NYU has done a lot of good work
looking at alcohol use disorder
otherwise known as alcoholism but the
names change every year it seems so it's
hard to keep track
I think there and this is speculation
but I think there is absolutely an
application to opioid use disorder to
even scratch the surface in terms of the
total addressable Market
with any of these compounds you need
regulatory oversight especially when
you're dealing with people who are using
other compounds whether those are
over-the-counter
say mood stabilizers and ssris and
different types of treatments along
those lines or people who are using
illicitly or using synthetic opioids but
abusing them you need you you really I
think need professional oversight right
and the professional oversight and the
regulatory landscape is going to be
dictated by the quality of science
that's coming out that's telling us
what's what's what it's going to be
dictated by the quality of the science
so this has been my
mission for the last handful of years I
mean there are a few problems that I've
used is very important and I also have
to separate out the problems that I can
have a meaningful impact on
versus those that
I within which I can't be effective
right so I wanted to get the flywheel
moving to the extent that I could with
funding early stage pilot studies so
that hopefully end initiatives like the
popular project at Harvard Law which is
focused on Law and regulation
specifically so that was the first of
its kind that I helped to co-fund
the journalism Etc there's the science
there's also a there are many issues
right insurance reimbursement Etc but to
even get to some of the let's just call
it Downstream issues that need resolving
you as a country also need a sufficient
pipeline of trained facilitators so one
of the initiatives for instance
that size a foundation is funded is
a project across Yale
Johns Hopkins and NYU
looking at how to develop a
set of curricula that can be plugged
into current
Psychiatry programs such that people who
are already opting into psychiatry
can develop the skills necessary if and
when these things are rescheduled or
made available on a Statewide basis that
they can be ready to catch the ball
right like a specialty a sub special
yeah yeah and that's really important
because as it stands right now it's a
chicken in the egg issue with respect to
say Federal funding so there's very
little Federal funding there have been a
few grants from the National Institute
on drug abuse I think I'm getting the
name right I always wonder if it's
institutes or Institute but Nida has for
instance made grants to Matt Johnson at
Johns Hopkins for tobacco nicotine
addiction
and there are a handful of others but
the funding tends to be pretty small in
order to get more funding what these
government agencies want to see is that
there is a plan and a reasonable plan
for Rolling these therapies out at scale
but how do you do that with a therapist
and how do you get a therapist without
the scientific funding so people are
willing to bet part of their careers on
it it's very very tricky so I would say
yes science which is why I focus there
and then secondarily or right alongside
it and there are other issues plenty of
other issues but would be therapist
training like how do you credential
how do you assure
quality control what is the necessary
level of training this is not a small
question right do they need to be as
good as these people have been doing it
for 20 years if so game over it's not
going to work or
is it enough if they already have say
good training with things like CBT or
DBT and or something like ifs if they
already have that can we pull from that
subpopulation of clinicians and they do
say a three-day course in my opinion and
I know this is not practical to do in
the US right now but ideally I think
each prescriber should have their own
experience on these compounds
which is very controversial but I think
it's irresponsible to prescribe these
things if you haven't had your own
experience they are categorically very
different from most psychiatric meds so
I know this is going to sound
a little wackadoodle to a lot of people
listening
but it's it's very challenging with
credibility to talk to someone about an
experience like this if you've never
experienced anything close to it and it
doesn't matter how much you read doesn't
matter how many documentaries you watch
it's it's one of those experiences where
I think the the outcomes will be better
if therapists have some at least passing
familiarity with the the phenomenology
right the first person experience of
taking some of these things which is
easier to do with something like MDMA
which is much easier to navigate much
easier to prescribe it's a lot easier to
manage than something that can get as
strange as say psilocybin and to your
point of
clinical application because of
pathology versus
let's just call it human flourishing or
Peak experiences I mean I think
sometimes it's like come for the trauma
stay for the mysticism okay I do think
people end up in many cases getting a
two for one I don't necessarily object I
don't object to healthy normals using
these compounds I mean this is true in
every indigenous population that I'm
aware of that uses any psychedelic
compound they are not used exclusively
for pathology in my experience
but
the Psychedelic world
and feel free to reel this in but I'll
just say one thing all I made a rant for
one second one of the biggest issues
with the Psychedelic Community which we
can't really call a community because of
the amount of infighting it is comically
bad how much infighting there is so if
you think these things automatically
result in World Peace just look at the
Psychedelic world right now oh my God
it's terrible but I would say that it's
not possible to boil the ocean at once
so a lot of people in the Psychedelic
World kind of make me think of the cars
you would see in like Berkeley
California where it's like on the back
of the car it's like safe to bet save
them save the whales coexist no oil for
such and such and they have 50 causes
which means they have no cause
effectively and there's a lot of I think
distraction which is not to minimize the
issues or the objectives that any of
these subgroups have but it's really
important to sequence them in a way that
makes sense and it makes sense to focus
on for instance veterans in the U.S who
have complex ptsda which is poorly
treated currently which results in
veteran suicides and extremely high
costs of health care for said veterans
right and which is a bipartisan you know
levels of opioid addiction opiate
addiction and I mean with I don't know
what the latest numbers are but I want
to say someone can fact check this but
it's only like 20 to 30 veteran suicides
a day I mean we lose more veterans to
suicide and veterans are important
because they have political immunity
no one can get up and say screw the
veterans so as far as acting as the tip
of the spear not just in combat but also
in the sphere of mental health they are
incredibly incredibly important so that
is a good place to start starting with
healthy normals Doom to fail that can
come later potentially but I would start
with healthy normals one more thing I'll
say just on the if if you don't mind on
the addiction front and on the 12-step
front there is a trend right now of
using ketamine in place of alcohol
and I know quite a few people this is
very common in La it's very common in
the coastal cities it's probably coming
elsewhere who are switching from alcohol
use to ketamine use and chronic ketamine
use has severe risks definitely has
addiction potential and it is a
dissociative anesthetic
thing guess what thank you alcohol
Frontier medicine same same sure and I I
do drink occasionally I think for me
there's a place for it
but I would not view ketamine as a
healthy substitute for alcohol and I did
a very comprehensive it is the most
comprehensive
podcast episode ever on ketamine with Dr
John Crystal who's well you weren't on
ketamine I was not on ketamines yes
thank you for the conversation we were
not on ketamine that would be very hard
to listen to Dr John Crystal of Yale who
has been the Principal investigator on a
lot of the foundational human research
with respect to ketamine and its
antidepressant properties and we did and
everything you could possibly want to
know about ketamine episode that I think
is three or four hours long and it
covers a lot of this but tldr chronic
use of ketamine is not good for you and
it makes you more prone to depression
yeah I I appreciate that kind of
addendum
um I went to treatment with a guy who
jumped off his roof on ketamine you know
it's like these are really powerful
compounds that need to be taken
seriously and uh and and also you know
to your point of the community sort of
being fractured it's also a case in
which they're all lumped together like
the psychedelics but like there's
massive differences between all of these
and they all have their their place in
different ways as somebody who has been
in this world for such a long time like
it does there's a very palpable sense
that society and culture is catching up
like this is this does seem to be
happening and progressing maybe not as
quickly as you would like
um but I do feel like this is moving to
me it feels like it's moving too fast I
would actually say because I've tried to
play a role with the podcast and other
interviews I've done for mainstream
magazines like fortune and others have
tried to change the national
conversation around these compounds
mostly to destigmatize funding so that
more funders from initially individual
and then later larger foundations would
come into the funding Circle
so I have made that a very deliberate
chess move on my part and other people
have certainly done amazing work I think
it is moving very quickly in some
respects the saturation is moving a
little faster than I would like because
the demand has so far outstripped
qualified
suppliers supervision
[Music]
and it's gonna be a bumpy ride I mean
we're going from the bunny slopes into
the Mogul field and that's to be
expected and when any compounds reach a
certain scale of use you run into lots
of issues yeah it really doesn't matter
what we're talking about and these
compounds generally generally there are
psychedelics that can kill you so that
there are certain designer psychedelics
that can kill you absolutely in excess
and you need to be very careful there
are also plenty of drugs masquerading as
other drugs so there are a lot of risks
however if we're talking about the most
researched and let's just focus on what
I would consider some of the classical
psychedelics like psilocybin incredibly
well physically tolerated so I'm not
aware of a known ld50 for this which
would mean
lethal dose 50s so a dose that would
hypothetically kill 50 percent of
participants let's just say of a
thousand people pulled from the
population at random what dose should
kill 500 of those people for many
compounds that's really well established
with psilocybin I'm not aware of any
known lv50 so it's very hard to have a
physiologically fatal
response but there are people who have
had
such a difficult emotional experience
that they've had heart attacks
I don't think there's having any trials
but it's certainly happened on the
Underground
and
the Aftercare is really Critical with
these things and which is why I
really
recommend people to do a lot of pre-work
and if you're not because if you're not
willing to do that pre-work if you're
not willing for instance Sam Harris
introductory course awareness these
things all layer in together if you're
not willing to do those two things if
you're not willing to engage with the
therapist to develop a rapport with
someone so that they can act as a safety
net if and when you decide to use one of
these compounds with someone else who
should be qualified
as a facilitator
you are not going to have the
wherewithal nor have you demonstrated
the will to do the rehab afterwards and
if you're not willing to do the rehab
afterwards you're asking for problems
really significant problems I think um I
want to move on to a different subject
but before we kind of close this chapter
what is the most exciting or interesting
science or research that's coming out
right now that has you kind of you know
fired up I'm excited by by a lot of it I
mean the basic science and looking at
Imaging and how these compounds affect
the brain is fascinating I'm very
interested in the new molecules that are
being created
very excited to
see more group therapy because I
actually
I would
wager so my hypothesis would be that
for a number of conditions and for a
number of compounds when used in
combination that the outcomes are
actually better not just less expensive
per person that would certainly be true
but more effective with greater
durability when you have group
integration maybe Group Training too
and that's very very exciting
it's also I think going to be a critical
consideration if we want these types of
treatments to be widely available with
any degree of access from a cost
perspective I would say that there are
certain molecules that are very bizarre
that say produce auditory Distortion but
that haven't been modeled well in animal
studies and raised all sorts of
interesting questions about
Consciousness I do find some of those
bigger questions very very interesting
if people want to get a decent idea of
the things I find interesting I'd
suggest Society it's just s-a-i-s-e-i
size foundation.org and you can look at
the projects page and there's quite a
bit there there's science and then also
on the other hand we didn't get into
this we don't have to spend a lot of
time on it but quite a bit of work with
conservation and preservation indigenous
Traditions Etc preserving indigenous
knowledge predict protecting those
groups against biopiracy things like
this I view that as a moral obligation
so I do that as well yeah it's cool what
does cise
means a few things in Japanese but it
means rebirth so Psy
is like to repeat
uh it's that's the onyomi that's the
Chinese reading uh bit complicated to
get into the all the language stuff but
Psy is like again
uh and say is
to live or life so it's the same
character if someone goes to Japan
they're like
from the draft Nama is like raw or alive
it's the same character Sensei like
teacher which literally means born
before like
yeah before you say is the same
character so it means rebirth and that
that is not an overstatement for a lot
of people who fit the bill as good
candidates for this who take it
seriously with
qualified supervision and you are the
Sensei of site say
right
that's the title of the podcast yeah I'm
the I'm the tour bus driver of size a
foundation
um shifting gears a little bit here uh
I'm curious
as somebody who's who's been kind of a
public figure on the internet for for
such a long period of time OG blogger uh
you know somebody who is compiling an
email list before that was a thing like
you've been doing this for a long time
and along the way of course the books
and the podcast Etc but the internet has
a very different place today than it was
when we're getting older you were coming
up and I was coming up so I'm curious
about how you think about that like what
is the
state of influence the business of
influence today
um compared to the earlier days and does
that color or change how you think about
how you show up publicly like how does
that all work for you
well I might turn that around and ask
you the same thing yeah I'll I'll allow
you to go back your time
here
I never think about influence unless
it's very very specifically defined I
explore and have written about and talk
about things that are very personal for
me
whether their goals whether they are
interests whether they are Curiosities
whether they're pain points
that's it because at least when I do
that I know I have a guaranteed Market
of one mm-hmm
and that the process of doing the
research or interviewing someone will be
valuable to me that is the only reliable
ingredient that I have found for
sustained
excitement and just sufficient endurance
to do
what I've been doing yeah it has to be
that way it has to be a function and an
authentic outgrowth of your curiosity
and what is getting you excited
otherwise there's no way that you're
going to have any kind of long-term
viability you'll get bored you'll burn
out you'll lose interest and then the
task before you becomes impossible as
opposed to what you might do anyway
right so trying to live outside of those
external pressures or those incentives
that are increasingly becoming more and
more about audience capture audience
growth maximizing attention all of that
and trying to find a way to create from
a place of a purity and remember what
got you excited about it in the first
place for me is the only way to be able
to do it like as somebody who's been
podcasting over 10 years now and you've
I don't know what year you started
blogging sharing online 2008 seven six
two thousand six yeah
yeah so blogging 2006 thousand plus
posts
and then the podcast will be 10 years
next April 1.4 episodes on average per
week for 10 years which is wild to think
about
I would say that I am very very happy
when I'm investing I want to be at The
Cutting Edge when I am considering where
to place my personal time and
exploration I like being on the dull
Edge I didn't do any experiments with
even say tick tock until a year ago and
I wanted to abide my time because
I felt like the platform was problematic
on a number of levels talk about
bringing senses back online right when I
when I experimented with tick tock on
someone else's phone because I don't
have it on my phone that's a whole
separate conversation but my sort of
head heart gut response was not green
light green light green line right like
paying attention to
what people far smarter than me have
called the whole body yes conscious
leadership group talks quite a bit about
this but the full body yes that was not
a full body yes and so I pause these
days when I don't get a full body yes
whether it's with a guest a format an
experiment an event doesn't matter if I
don't get a full body S I at least want
to pause
and sit with that so I I say yes very
slowly to new platforms
does that mean I compromise audience
growth probably but the subsequent
question is so what mm-hmm I think for
most creators and I don't view myself as
that I I like I think it's it's a
hazardly
nebulous term
Creator I view myself as a podcaster
right now that's what I do
helps to keep me focused do you do you
consider yourself a writer
I am writing fiction right now which is
a whole separate thing and nonetheless
right now I don't call myself a writer I
was out I was written multiple New York
number one New York Times bestselling
books I was at a dinner I was at a
dinner just a few days ago and a friend
of mine was there uh Neil Strauss
amazing writer very consistent and
somebody asked me what I did and I was
and I was like well you know former
writer but now I do a b and c and he's
like former writer and I texted Neil the
other day and I said what should I ask
Tim he's coming in he's like he's
calling himself a former writer oh
that's hilarious okay yeah yeah so I I
say that just because
look I I'm not attached to former writer
sure I can say writer that's fine I'm
okay with it but it's kind of like if
last time I went surfing was 20 years
ago and I was really stoked about it for
five years but then I stopped should I
call myself a surfer I don't know maybe
not it's so I find there's just a
finality to that word there's a finality
I'm very careful with the labels I apply
to myself I think very carefully about
the labels I apply once you apply a
label you start to use confirmation bias
or warp your perception in ways that are
even hard to track so I I'm very careful
with the labels I apply but
to come back to your question if you
were to talk to most creators these days
and I get tons of questions online and
meet a lot of them in person and if you
were to just drill in on their let's say
strategies they're using for audience
growth
and say and why
and why
and why or for what for what so that
what will happen if you get three layers
deep very often there aren't very good
answers
there are some very impressive people
who execute super well and they have
coherent strategies and because they use
let's just say different ad models or
they have sponsorship deals or native
advertising even though I hate native
advertising because to me that means
hidden advertising which I think is
disgusting and unethical we don't have
to spend a lot of time on that most
people are creating because the
algorithms and the data scientists and
teams behind them have figured out how
to make you feel like you're sitting at
the slots in the airport in Vegas and
you're getting a little drip
of dopamine every time you get a hit
every 15 minutes even though you're
getting blood of chips and those chips
are by getting blood of your coin your
money in this case it's your time it's
your attention because the reason you
don't pay for
these platforms is because you're the
product
yes you are the product being sold and I
for that reason up until very recently
had no
social apps I've not had any social apps
on my phone for about either two or
three years and then began experimenting
with a handful of things because I
launched uh you know this art project to
raise money for the foundation and
Twitter
required me to install the app to really
use Twitter spaces effectively and I was
like oh you rap bastards you got me okay
fine just uninstalled that
but generally I simply recognize I know
I've shifted to the consumer seat but
you were bringing a knife to a gunfight
if you think you can use self-control
to use these apps in any way that is not
distracting you from your main focus
so from the from the Creator standpoint
I also think I've gotten to a point
where if if I go through the for what
for what for what exercise myself
the only reason that I could defend with
metrics is probably ultimately Financial
if I have more downloads I can charge
more for sponsorship I do have reasons
for the email list but that's separate
we could talk about that actually that's
very old school talk about old-fashioned
yeah but it's so old it's new it's so
old it's new funny how that works and
the financial argument for me
is it's it's compelling on some levels
right it would give me more funding for
the foundation but I have not in a
really compelling way found that more
money helps me achieve any of my current
goals or solve any of my current
problems any faster it's kind of a goal
I need to smirk at if I'm using that I'm
like I don't even believe what I'm
saying right right like 25 year old Tim
yeah and I that's as someone might point
out it's very easy for someone to say if
you're sitting in a financial position
that's very comfortable which is totally
fair but certainly past past a point
like collecting more Marbles and buying
more Skittles just doesn't do much
it's it you can use it for for things in
the world yes but
so for that reason I've really tried to
keep track of I sound like such an old
bastard but it's like how do I feel when
I wake up how easily am I falling asleep
what's my quality of sleep
and if the answer is not so great for a
couple of days looking at the activities
people I'm interacting with the things I
said yes to that I should have said no
to and God damn it when I looked at that
email I knew it was going to be you know
I couldn't say it because I felt some
social obligation or pressure or
whatever I'm afraid of somebody smack
talking me to their brother-in-law who
the hell knows something stupid keeping
track of that and when I keep track of
that stuff generally I come to the
conclusion that I really enjoy long-form
audio I love the freedom of having a
recording studio in my backpack
and
I probably shouldn't spend a lot of time
on video as one example yeah even though
the rewards are there I understand what
those rewards could be but it's anti
it's antithetical to some of the aspects
of the whole podcasting game that made
it so appealing in the beginning right
from the beginning you had this whole
thing about making sure that it it
remained facile so that it would be an
easy lift for you and being very mindful
yes about not over complicating it even
in the equipment that you bought like
each new piece of equipment being a
multiplier as a point of failure like
all of that was kind of built in to your
operating system from the get-go
and you even said recently like I'm so
glad I started a podcast when you didn't
have to produce a television show you
know because that's really what it is
and yeah we've taken different different
paths with this
um well let me first just say just to
kind of button up the the discussion
around influence like I appreciated what
you had to share and I think the
conversation has become too much about
you know attention and followers and
growth and not enough attention on value
and how you're contributing and how
you've made that not only meaningful for
yourself but meaningful for the audience
that you've built right and what is that
audience and you know are you uplifting
them are you educating them like what is
it that you are providing them with and
is that kind of a net positive for the
world like maybe we should be talking
more about that right like and I think
we both approach the podcast with our
own versions of that perspective and
Longevity is built out of making sure
that you know curiosity is always at the
root and the choices around guests come
from a genuine place of you know wanting
to learn from that person and continue
to expand our own respective Horizons
and in turn like deliver that to an
audience in a way that can be beneficial
to them but to the point of you know the
way in which we're doing our podcast
like okay we've made a different
decision we've invested in this studio
and we are producing a television show
and it's like a studio it's a whole
thing right that's nice and uh and and
you were sharing at lunch like yeah
there's times where I wish you know
maybe I should have like done you know
done gotten in on it and then I would if
I'm being honest I would say well I wish
there were times where I was it was just
me just me in a suitcase and like
everything is a lot simpler you know
yeah I wouldn't trade the way that I'm
doing it to go back there but they have
their pluses and their minuses right and
I think you know when we kind of
welcomed this type of creation into you
know what we do here it it does make it
um it makes it more interesting and it's
fun and I love sharing the videos and
being able to provide that for the
guests and to kind of amplify them in
that way
um but it takes a lot more people and
it's an investment and you have to
manage those people and you're not as
Nimble and you can't you know kind of
pivot in the way that you're able to and
so I think you're doing it exactly the
way that that you should be doing it for
yourself thank you if you're true to
those that original value set yeah the
the podcasting Peter Pan I like it but
it is it is like podcasting has changed
a lot right now it's just like when we
started like I didn't I never thought it
would be a business at all let alone
like the business that has become for
myself and for others and I'm super
aware and grateful
that I've benefited from the fact that
like I was early on when it wasn't
competitive because launching a show
today no matter who you are it's
incredibly difficult to differentiate
yourself yes I'd say just a few things
before I forget the first is that we
entered the game at a very particular
point we also laid groundwork in the
form of books and other things and we
ended up with the ability to interview
people on a very wide range of subjects
for somebody starting if you wanted to
begin in podcasting I think you probably
I would probably recommend you do what I
did in the blogging World which is you
start very very like if you want to go
wide eventually
start very Niche now and if you want to
be very big
later
start very slow in a sense with your
deliberate choices now right like the
slow is smooth and smooth as fast
kind of approach if you're playing a
long game right now you might be saying
I'm not playing the long game I want to
Sprint for three to five years and then
have my YouTube channel bought by
someone for seven figures okay
that's a fair game it's also a very
binary game
and if it doesn't work out yeah you may
think you're gonna be able to let go of
it but if you've got all these great
sponsor deals and suddenly you're the
I don't know I bounce on a trampoline
while playing you know the latest pop
song on harmonica if that's your thing
you may get sick of doing that at some
point so but I would say starting Niche
early
is is oftentimes smart so you just kind
of get a foot in the door and then over
time and Matt cuts
formerly of Google called this the
Katamari I think it's the Katamari it's
reference to this Japanese video game
approach where you sort of roll up this
tiny ball and the ball gets bigger and
bigger over the time so in the beginning
you're picking up like paper clips and
so on that's the really narrow Focus
let's just say for me it's like all
right four hour work week stuff email
management productivity and then as it
gets slightly wider it's like all right
we're now really talking about is
optimization so we can hop over to
physical performance
and then we go from optimization to like
well wait a second what the hell are we
optimizing for okay and now it broadens
and invites more questions and in case
the podcast more guess but I do think
that and this will tie into your
influence comment never has the Kevin
Kelly piece on true fans been more
relevant so just search Kevin Kelly true
fans on kk.org and look that up and when
thinking of influence I think it it is
very helpful to first ask yourself what
do you want to influence before you
start trying to influence or becoming an
influencer come on Tim what do you want
to change I ran on My Parade I just want
to be an influencer what do you want to
change so in my case
the type of questions I have been asking
myself for a long time but especially
let's just say six seven years ago to
give a concrete example
I start really researching the ecosystem
with respect to psychedelics
trying to identify and this is very
critical the uncrowded high leverage
areas where I am uniquely suited to make
a difference where other people cannot
do the same thing easily then I start
asking myself all right let's say there
are four of those
let me put those four in rank order like
which one of these makes the others
easier or irrelevant okay Trent learn
which one of these naturally leads to
the next great let me try to put these
in some semblance of order and then I
just ask if I had a room full of a
thousand people
and I wanted to make these changes
happen or to facilitate these types of
things who are those thousand people
and then I can start to think
strategically about what type of guests
I want to have on what types of
questions I want to ask on social who I
want to follow on Twitter and let's just
say they're involved in some aspect of
government favorite and retweet
something so hopefully their staffer
takes notice
and then and only then maybe a few weeks
later publish something that I hope will
get the attention of someone in that
office and then only a month after that
reach out to someone to have
conversation and or perhaps they get
mentioned in a podcast episode and these
are these are not accidental things
generally right that's like Inception
level uh intentionality because I think
there should be a what and furthermore
there should be a really important why
when it comes to influence and I
recognize that depending on where you
are on mazzo's hierarchy of needs the
why it might be I want to be able to
leave my soul-crushing job and pay for
my rent and cover my kids school without
having a panic attack every evening
great
that's super legitimate I I think that
it's it's simply worth examining the
what and the why so that you're clear
because even if you're just being
purely mercenary about things let's just
say you're not trying to make making the
world a better place is too big it's for
a little bit later you have other goals
you want to check off first because you
feel like you need to do those things
for your individual life or your family
life before you can even consider those
bigger
aspirations
it still makes sense to go through
and ask these questions yeah because
even if that is the case and you are on
that that level of the the hierarchy of
needs there still needs to be a lot of
intentionality brought into the value
proposition of what you're what you're
kind of putting out there right and and
objectively you know examining the worth
of that before you even get out of the
gate yeah totally yeah what is the um
process by which you select guess is it
like do you have a whole like sort of
checklist strategy in terms of like who
you invite on the show there are it
could be
coming at me from any number of vectors
I'd say
if a friend I respect
whose seldom makes recommendations
puts their social capital on the line
like puts their reputation at risk to
say 10 out of 10 I recommend you
consider this person as a guest
I don't have to have any interest in the
subject matter at all if if someone is
willing to kind of put their neck on the
line I take it seriously since my
friends generally take that type of
thing as seriously as I do they don't
come very often right away but when they
do I pay attention if I have any type of
strain I'm looking to remove from my
life or
pleasure slash fun I'm looking to inject
in my life goal I'm looking to achieve
fair game that's going to be podcast is
going to be one of the
the tools that I bring to bear on that
yeah let's see certainly for policy
change and things like that uh it it's
the way that I have discussed
psychedelics on the podcast over many
years now I mean since 2000 probably 14
15.
is is not haphazard so I it could be
trying to correct a narrative or ad
perhaps an understated risk to the
conversation
as would be the case with ketamine for
instance because there are plenty of
people who will not listen to me but
they will listen to someone like Dr John
Crystal and in turn maybe you listen and
you don't use ketamine but you know five
friends who do
and without making it too on the nose
you have I think you have a problem you
should listen to this and be like hey
this is really interesting you should
listen to it and just as a trojan horse
they all get exposed to it so I do think
about
from a public service or ultimate
long-term objective within the ecosystem
of say science regulation law policy Etc
I do think about it that's not a primary
driving factor I have stepped back from
engaging with most of the Psychedelic
world because they're just so many
clowns it is so this is where I need
more DBT but it is so upsetting to me
I'm just like God fight it out
my God you could not ask for a more
clown-like composition there are great
people also but there are just so many
yahoos
and uh so I tend to be very surgical in
how I approach it
uh and it could be it could be someone
also if if I'm doing a lot of heavy
lifting and a bunch of serious
interviews or things I'm taking
seriously
it could just be something for fun right
have a friend on I'm going to do a
random show with Kevin Rose soon
which I do every once in a while that's
why it's called the random show close
friend he's great at conversation and it
is our excuse to catch up right right
he's busier than hell I make myself busy
with who the hell knows what half the
time and we just get a Time on the
calendar we yeah it's fun you guys [__]
around and I think it's important to
have that kind of light touch with it
too and not take it too seriously and
not be afraid to you know mix it up with
the with the formats and you know the
approach to it and you did that with uh
with the cockpot saying and you know all
of that you got to like you know sow
some Wild Oats and and you know have fun
and I think that's important in terms of
longevity as well
um the other thing you've done a pretty
good job of is is really making sure
that that the conversations are
Evergreen and kind of stepping outside
of this flywheel that exists that many
people may not even realize exists in
the podcast world where you know it's
all about like the book of the the week
right like there's always you know every
you get I'm sure you're on the same
email list that I am and you're you're
you know you're getting pitched these
guests all the time and there's kind of
an incentive structure set up to host
these types of conversations and the
publishing companies have figured out
that podcasts sell books so they have a
a deep incentive to try to book their
authors on all these shows I've tried
pretty hard to kind of begin to St I was
part a like sort of a big participant in
that for a while and I really like
Endeavor to get out of that game because
it's exhausting and the guests that you
host ends up
on the same day and so as I've sort of
but I'll make exceptions for friends for
books that I think are really you know
like worthy of uh you know of having a
conversation with people that I admire
because sometimes it gives you access to
somebody who you wouldn't ordinarily get
to sit down with like Matthew
McConaughey or you know Rick Rubin or
what have you those are the occasions
where our shows will will overlap yeah
and you my friend are a god damn ninja
because no matter what your episode
always comes out first so you're
practicing some kind of Art of War
[__] to make sure that no matter
what knowing that this author is going
to be going on a bunch of shows that
you're that you're coming out first so
you win congratulations the dark arts I
hope you feel good about it
I just had to call you out on that
because we're like over here I'm gonna
like God damn it he did it again yeah
you know you know there there are all
fair and loving podcasting but I I have
really tried to step back it's tough
because there are people I would like to
have on and everybody and their
Grandma's coming out with a book these
days so it makes me so uncomfortable
when it's friends yeah it's it's
uncomfortable and
I have found it uh
largely unproductive I would say to have
on people who are on like six podcasts
in the same week it's it's a level of
saturation that I think in some cases
leads listeners to opt out and I
understand the incentive structures I
mean podcasts or the new radio
effectively and the incentives are also
on the podcasters side if they have a
big guest they know it's going to get
views or downloads there are aligned
incentives
from that perspective but
in my ideal world and it's not always
Tim's Ideal World but in my ideal world
I would be having novel conversations
that bring something to my audience they
wouldn't have found otherwise yeah and
that and that's what feels the best too
yeah when you find that person who's
amazing who isn't necessarily promoting
anything they just have something wise
about them and something that you
resonate with that you know your
audience will and and just the the
feeling of being able to like like check
this out you know and have people
respond to that is like that's the juice
yeah and I that's also where the
this psychedelic ecosystem with respect
to scientists has actually been a
godsend of sorts because I get to have
those conversations and I think that
scientific literacy just having a basic
fundamental ability to say read
headlines and the news with an ability
to sort fact from fiction or at least
know which questions to ask so that you
can interrogate
these Sensational stories
is crucial survival training for the
information age that we live in it's
going to get so bad with AI I mean the
disinformation is going to get so
shockingly bad that taking it upon
yourself it doesn't take very long it's
like take a week or two and just decide
I'm going to become
functionally literate
in how to
understand 20 terms in science that's it
and Peter Tia who's who's been mentioned
earlier has a great series called
studying the studies I think it is it's
a bit technical
one of his podcasts is quite good
there's a book called bad science which
has some excellent chapters in it which
which helps you to start to parse see
through the Veil
uh it doesn't have to be that
intimidating yeah so in any case these
are things I care about the scientific
literacy
is is really important to me right what
it what is the most unoptimized area of
your life
that you would that you're like
embarrassed to admit I am now a
connoisseur of on optimizing or
de-optimizing
I have come to really appreciate
poetry that sounds so ridiculous I I
mean the younger me would really just be
throwing fits hearing this but reading
really good poetry that has been
thoughtfully in most cases translated so
there's a book it's very thin it's
called gold it's new translations of
Rumi by uh this woman uh
our last name is
halagaphori no it's Halal gafori
g-a-f-o-r-a and they're just
spectacularly
beautiful in some cases hilarious poems
you can really chew on
and that would be one area social time
I've realized from my mental health
group dinners are just a layup every
time if I have one or two group dinners
with friends per week
more than one person
two or three people
I'm generally great if I do that
exercise I'm pretty good even if I even
if I I could be characterized as
optimizing your emotional health well
maybe I mean I think optimizing it have
more constraints around it but like
these tend to go for a long time and if
it's like somebody's birthday and
they're like hey let's have a drink and
I'm like I really don't want to drink
because sleep is number one like I'll
make compromises here and there so I'm
adding the the mental health piece
more isn't
as in as an afternote if that makes
sense it's the driver is
trying to embrace unrushed enjoyment
which has been de-prioritized for most
of my life yeah yeah yeah like unrushed
the hell are you talking about enjoyment
save that for later yeah right yeah your
your reward is you you perform well
that's your rule yeah do your job I mean
listen and you're walking it because you
you know we talked about having lunch
beforehand maybe going on a hike and
you're like I got time like you're not
like right you don't you're not like
rushing out of here because you got some
other appointments so clearly you you're
like doing that you're showing up for
that and you're like yeah and I decided
for this set of a few weeks when I'm in
La that it was social over solo and
there are compromises like in terms of
productivity it's falling through the
floor like however I might measure
productivity I mean it's it's
plummeted and what I've realized for
myself and maybe this applies to people
might help folks think about say the
mental health stuff which is if you're
far on one end let's just say
productivity efficiency I don't read
fiction because it's a waste of time if
I want to make up stories I can do
myself like that kind of person which I
was forever you may need to experiment
with doing the opposite which is
some form of this like total immersion
stuff that I'm doing right now before
right it's like thesis antithesis
synthesis before you can end up in the
middle
okay with some medley that you can
sustain for a long time you might have
to
explore the the end ranges so for me
right now that's that's social so today
totally unrushed it's great yeah well
the final one is the low hanging fruit
most obvious one which is
what would you put on a billboard and
maybe you know how you answer that uh is
a reflection on
how you've changed or grown since the
last time I saw you so last time
I saw you my answer probably would have
been you're the average of the five
people you associate with most something
like that right
pick your
pick your Social Circle very wisely that
includes virtual or parasocial
Relationships by the way like the people
you follow on YouTube or podcasts choose
carefully the answer I would give now
I'm going to crib directly from
a former guest of mine Dr B.J Miller
who's helped a thousand plus probably
two thousand plus people
to transition to death and hospice care
fascinating guy and I think he got it
from a bumper sticker but it's great and
I think it
sort of wraps everything nicely for me
right now which is don't believe
everything you think I don't believe
everything you think really
take a second to encourage interrogate
those things look for counter evidence
and
there's so many stories so many beliefs
right which are thoughts we take to be
true that we've repeated for so long
that they've become the subconscious Ten
Commandments through which we live our
lives
and
it's an ongoing process but don't
believe everything you think um
there's a lot of depth to that and a lot
of layers yeah I love it
um this is great man thank you yeah I
really enjoyed it
um it's a privilege to kind of witness
your your Arc and your growth and like I
said at the outset your transparency and
your courage and your vulnerability
around sharing it I really do think it's
a salve and just so many people and and
helpful and and there's a true
commitment to service you know that's
behind it that I think is really
laudable and uh and and worthy of notes
so you know thank you for doing that and
uh I'm at your service my friend
anything I can do to to help
um Advance the things that you're
interested in uh I hope you consider me
a resource thanks man yeah and may I may
I plug all your stuff come on dude
what are we doing here yeah what are we
doing here all right finally I can pitch
my [__] uh uh thank you for that I
appreciate it and
I mean I'm here for a while be nice to
actually spend a couple hours together
go for a hike
so a few things I would say first is if
people are interested in
learning what the coolest most
interesting things are that I'm coming
across and there are a lot of them I
have a newsletter it's one of the
biggest single author newsletters out
there it's free Bible at Friday Tim dot
blog Friday you can find that I love
doing that it's actually really fun to
go back and look at them because it's
kind of the only thing I have that's
close to a diary so I had to go back
like three years ago and see oh
that's what was happening that week
that's why I got that thing because I
broke my toe and this and that and oh
yeah I forgot about that documentary so
five bullet Friday for people who might
be interested a couple million people
subscribe it's a lot of fun
and then uh the podcast of course Tim
Ferriss show you can find that and I
think a good place to start if you want
somebody you probably haven't been
exposed to
this is an old one you can find all the
big names and all that but BJ Miller
that was feels like a hundred years ago
that was probably 2015. that to this day
is one of those episodes that I think
about all the time so people are looking
for a name they might not recognize
you can check that one out cool man
we'll link that up also so all right man
well hopefully to be continued yeah to
be continued man it's great to see you
thanks you too as well cheers peace